Uh, I'm, uh, an entrepreneur and a practical type for me.
The problem I was trying to solve for seven years was that we weren't creating
enough new businesses and entrepreneurship and, uh,
business growth and job growth in communities around the country.
And then I realized that the problems were much bigger and deeper,
but certainly Andrew Yang in his late twenties was not thinking any of this
Andrea and his late twenties was just trying to get a deal.
I think what's interesting. And what captured so many,
so much interest about your candidacy and more was you didn't talk,
you talk about it in terms of the fourth industrial revolution, obviously,
you know, we I've,
I've interviewed you in the past and you obviously understand some of the
deeper, I mean, obviously you did the math,
but you also spoke about it in a very visceral way.
So when you were traveling those places and you're talking to these people,
how do they come through? Like in their stories?
Because something that I've always kind of come to understand is that elite
economists and many others will try to explain phenomenon way by being like, no,
your job has gone, but you you're better off because of X.
And that when you actually talk to real voters and people who have been effected
by automation, trade policy, or LOC last loss of manufacturing,
they know exactly why they lost their job and the macro force that it kind of
brought about. So is that something that you saw,
like whenever you were traveling?
Yeah, they did know what happened, particularly in a place like Detroit,
where the urban center emptied out for the most part
and the population drained away. Uh,
and they know that it was a combination of globalization and trade deals and
offshoring, and also, uh,
the automation of many of their traditional manufacturing jobs. So they know,
uh, and I studied economics.
So I understand the theory behind it, uh, you know, like, Oh,
comparative advantage, you'll be fine. Or, you know,
you'll learn how to do something that's higher value add. Uh,
but then you go there and that stuff's just seems farcical. You go there.
Right. Uh,
and there was a disconnect that I struggled with.
And then Trump won in 2016. I started a venture for America in 2011.
So I've been doing that work for five years and then Trump wins and then I'm
like, okay, this is much deeper and nastier, and we're still,
we're still not being honest about it somehow. So that, that was what drove me,
but I, I am very interested in trying to figure out the Genesis of my, um,
uh, of my approach in part, because, uh, you know,
I've been an operator and entrepreneur for 20 years or so, uh,
and you know, they're just like facts on the ground that you have to deal with.
And if you tell yourself a nonsense story and you're running a private
company, uh, you're going to fail, but like, it's, it's,
you know, it's inevitable. And so, you know,
I like to think I just traffic in, uh,
as close a version of reality is I can find, um, because if,
if you're operating from reality, then you're more likely to be successful.
And one of the frustrations I found soccer is that, like,
there's not a whole lot of trafficking in reality, that's going on right now.
Uh, and it's going to destroy us because we have this increasingly in Kuwait,
uh, set of arguments. Uh, and one thing that someone said to me,
it was only as Lessig, um,
who said to me that we live in a [inaudible] right now where I can't get
anything done, but I can keep you from getting anything done. Right.
And so there's a lot of negative power going on. Um,
and we're in an era of unprecedented change.
And so if you freeze government and say, no one can get anything done,
then you wind up with, uh,
problems that just get bigger and bigger and you become more and more behind the
curve and out of date.
I think that's a really profound point that you're making there, Andrew,
because the,
the main thing that you're observing is that we can stop things from other
getting done. And like I was saying, like,
I generally find the whole shtick about businessman trying to run the country
that way as pretty hokey, because it's like, well, no,
actually like a nation state is not a business and all that.
But the one thing where I think it absolutely does apply is to your point was is
that if you keep, if you do something, which is totally delusional,
you generally, your business should fail.
Like there should be at least some sort of incentive,
theoretically that's in democracy, like voters should vote you out,
if you do fail.
And yet we've kind of come to a system where you have both parties,
which are invested very much in an ideology, which has failed, you know,
the fourth industrial revolution as you call it,
didn't really just occur out of nowhere. One of the, you know, the deep,
one of the most pernicious things that somebody told me,
I won't name him because he was high level in economics. He said, you know,
I'm unconvinced that the best scenario for Amazon is
not 10% unemployment or, you know, PERMA 10 to 15% unemployment.
And the reason being that if you're in a rural or a small town,
that the best pay, the best paying job, so to speak.
And really the only option for you is to work in an Amazon warehouse at a very
set wage in a, not which is non-unionized.
And there is a level of corporate control there over the way that you're
conducting your life. And your, you know, you, you,
your singular option of being able to live that I do think is unacceptable.
How do you, how have you always looked at the monopolization question?
Cause I know you toyed with it, you know,
between tech and then the regular sector too.
I don't think we have truly reckoned with what it means to have trillion dollar
companies that dominate so much of our waking
life. Uh, you know, and it was to me,
a source of great amusement watching these trillion
dollar companies pretend to be scrappy startups in front of Congress the other
way, it was like, Oh, you know, we're not number one at all.
We could be appended any day by those tick talkers or whatever. It's like,
we wouldn't have crushed Instagram. No, you know, it's like the whole thing.
I'm just like, Ugh. Yeah. Like watching them, uh,
try and recast themselves. Um,
yeah, that, that there are consequences of having companies of that scale, uh,
are unknown to us. Uh, but they're extreme.
And one of the things I kept saying to folks is like, look at this point, um,
Amazon no longer, uh, has to obey the rules of business physics anymore.
It's just like this voracious black hole. Yeah. Uh, you know,
it's,
it could decide not to make money in a given quarter and it would still be a
trillion dollar company. You can't compete with them in any meaningful way.
They have essentially unlimited resources and
access to more data than anyone else. Uh, you know, that like they're,
they'll trumpet the fact that they're hiring tens of thousands of Americans
while, uh,
while retail is shutting down and I mean made light of it earlier about what's
going to happen. Uh, and, and so the, the old tool kit would be like, well,
break them up.
And I think that there needs to be a breakup of some of these companies in some
verticals. Uh,
but I also don't think that actually solves the problem because you wind up
with, uh, still, uh,
these network effects that just advantage whatever company is, uh,
is at the hub.
And right now our government is so bad at this where we're essentially 25 years
behind the curve.
So any company that's come into existence over the last 25 years? Oh no, no, no.
What you're doing. Uh, and then we have this mistrust of government being like,
well, you're slow and behind the times, and they're right. Really smart.
And the times they should decide what to do. Uh, and, uh,
and that that's been, um, one of the ways we're conditioned. Uh,
so the optimal path would be that we go to each of
the big four or five companies and just say, look,
we have company-specific issues with you trying to apply a one size fits all
antitrust framework doesn't even make sense, right?
Like we're going to have to craft tailored legislation, um,
and figure out what the worst aspects of your enormity
are and then circumscribed them. So in Facebook's case, it might be like, well,
what are our biggest beefs with you? Uh, the erosion or, uh,
or near decimation of our democracy, I would say,
would be top of the list. Uh,
and then the fact that they sell and resell Austin,
our data for tens of billions of dollars a year might be second.
Then the third might be, uh,
the fact that they have a near monopoly on certain types of social media,
because they did by Instagram and WhatsApp.
And so maybe we have to do something about that.
And then there might be mental health of our kids associated with Instagram,
use you down the list and just try and figure out what, what each issue is.
Um, like I'm not against size for sizes sake, I'm against size of it ends up,
um, hurting us in various ways.
And then you have to write company specific legislation, um,
for Facebook, essentially, don't pretend it's like,
we're going to take out a 20th century framework before the internet even
existed back when they're talking about picking,
like this company makes too much steel.
Like it's a very, very different world now.
Yeah. I th it's, it's funny, you said I,
what I always loved about your campaign was the feeling that I wasn't living
in ossified, Washington, you know, like,
cause I've covered these guys on Capitol Hill and so much more. And it was,
I I'll never forget him being like, why does my iPhone listen to me?
And I was like, all right,
like when you're going up to Mark Zuckerberg and you're asking,
how does Facebook make money? It's like, okay. I mean, you're just wasting,
you know, you have a finite amount of time.
Whenever you get to ask questions here, it used to drive me absolutely nuts.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.